[Music]
so where are your wing folks dem kids oh
you know what they were trying to get
down here but there were mommy in Vegas
for her shows you know they get to go on
stage you still go see him do you still
get wowed by Mariah singing cuz I do Oh
two nights ago tonight say go on Vegas
amazing she set it off yeah yeah and I
use me a kitten the kids on their side
dancing this thing so it's a good time
even one of them have voices there's
some skill there's yeah we're
cultivating it so so rock and roll come
to you and they literally say mom dad we
want to do this they've been in the
studio they got records it's all like it
this is poppy they'll grow up in this I
don't like I know the the the trajectory
King if you don't really focus on it but
again I'm all for what kids love to do
do you have a new girl I don't have a
girlfriend you don't you are you dating
I'm always dating yeah why not
I'm almost single man I'm supposed to do
what you gonna let your heart fall in
love again yeah I'll broken I'm
shattered what are you just okay then
you're Mariah both need to get back
together because both ears you can't
compare to you still not Nikki Mariah no
that was a special time yeah I mean but
you know we are we made some amazing
children together you did and so we
always will always be together
you